ahora los problemas se van a poner un
poquito más interesantes digamos por
ejemplo que tenemos aquí una urna una
urna es como no sé como un jarrón de
esos que tenían los griegos y adentro de
la urna digamos que tenemos un montón de
monedas aunque aquí están todas nuestras
monedas pero no todas estas monedas son
iguales
digamos que tenemos adentro de la urna
nueve monedas normales
mal
donde por normales me refiero a que son
no sé cómo pesos mexicanos que tienen de
un lado un águila y del otro lado tienen
un sol pero una de estas monedas es una
moneda muy especial ok es una moneda que
no es como todas las demás que de un
lado tiene sol pero del otro en lugar de
tener allí la tiene otro sol
ahora a esta moneda que tiene dos soles
le vamos a empezar a llamar la moneda
2s y a estas nueve monedas que son
normales para no tener que escribir todo
el tiempo normales nada más vamos a
escribir ok
bueno y el chiste es que vamos a tomar
al azar una moneda de esta urna de
monedas pero no vamos a poder saber qué
moneda estamos tomando ok digamos que es
algo que no podemos saber con el sentido
del tacto de hecho si quieres puedes
pensar que te pusieron unos guantes y
entonces no hay forma de hacer trampa tú
metes la mano y sacas una moneda de los
días que hay con la misma probabilidad y
una vez que tomaste una moneda vas a
lanzar las cinco veces ok
vientos que bueno pude haber puesto o
lados en lugar de lanzamientos pero pues
ya ni modo y lo que nos queremos
preguntar es cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener cinco soles en esos cinco
lanzamientos
ok tenemos aquí el experimento tenemos
una urna o una bolsa si quieres con
nueve monedas normales y una moneda que
tiene dos soles tomamos la moneda sin
observar qué tipo de moneda tomamos la
lanzamos cinco veces y nos preguntamos
cuál es la probabilidad que en esos
cinco lanzamientos hayamos sacado cinco
soles bueno podemos empezar por sacar
cuál es la probabilidad de que no salga
una moneda normal y esa probabilidad la
de sacar una moneda normal es igual a
haber tenemos diez monedas y sacar
cualquiera de esas monedas tiene la
misma probabilidad
entonces esto es una cuestión de casos
favorables entre casos totales así es
que hay diez posibles resultados porque
hay diez monedas y hay nueve monedas que
son normales entonces tenemos nueve
casos favorables y ahora podemos sacar
cuál es la probabilidad de sacar justo
la moneda que tiene dos soles entonces
eso vamos a ponerlo como la probabilidad
de sacar la moneda de dos soles entonces
casos totales son diez y casos
favorables pues hay una sola moneda con
dos soles ok también estamos suponiendo
que sacas una y solo una moneda ok no se
vale no sacar nada entonces pues la
verdad es que hay muchas formas de sacar
esta probabilidad pero pues vamos a
hacer una de ellas digamos que estamos
aquí cuando empieza el experimento y
pues algo muy importante pasa al inicio
del experimento no algo que la verdad es
que determina cómo va a suceder el resto
del experimento cuando metemos la mano a
la urna y sacamos una moneda podemos
sacar una moneda normal normal
o podemos justo sacar la moneda que
tiene dos soles y sacamos la moneda de
dos soles con probabilidad 1 entre 10 y
sacamos una moneda normal con
probabilidad 9 entre 10 pero bueno el
chiste es que una vez que ya sacamos una
moneda normal estamos suponiendo que
sabemos que ya sacamos una moneda normal
entonces nos podemos preguntar cuál es
la probabilidad de que en los cinco
volados
las dos nos salgan cinco soles
que es justo la probabilidad que
queremos sacar pero aquí tenemos que
tomar en cuenta que estamos suponiendo
que ya sabemos que sacamos una moneda
normal aunque entonces para denotar eso
lo que hacemos siempre es poner una
línea grandota por acá que divide la
condición de la que queremos sacar la
probabilidad con respecto a lo que
estamos suponiendo que ya sabemos aquí
esta es la condición de la cual queremos
saber la probabilidad sacar cinco soles
en cinco volados y lo que estamos
suponiendo que ya sabemos es que sacamos
una moneda normal entonces aquí vamos a
poner que sacamos una moneda normal
aunque todo esto denota cuánto
calculamos que es la probabilidad de
sacar cinco soles en cinco volados dado
que nos encontramos en este punto donde
tenemos una moneda normal que todo este
tiempo estado diciendo que sabemos que
tenemos una moneda normal pero la verdad
es que a veces no sabemos nada más
estamos suponiendo que sacamos una
moneda normal
ahora está probabilidad ya la sacamos
así como dos vídeos creo o sea tenemos
simplemente una moneda normal
echamos cinco volados y nos preguntamos
cuál es la probabilidad de que salgan
cinco soles y habíamos visto que eso es
igual a un medio elevado al número de
volados que es 5 que hay que es igual a
1 entre 32 y por aquí pasa lo mismo o
sea si llegamos a sacar la moneda que
tiene 2 soles
la probabilidad de obtener 5 soles en 5
lados
dado que tenemos la moneda que tiene dos
soles aquí esta línea de aquí significa
que estamos suponiendo que sucede esto
de que tenemos justo la moneda que tiene
dos soles y bueno si tenemos la moneda
que tiene dos soles y echamos cinco
volados pues obviamente en esos cinco
volados van a salir cinco soles no osea
aunque tenemos mil veces esa moneda como
únicamente tiene soles siempre nos van a
salir soles entonces dado que tenemos a
la moneda con dos soles la probabilidad
de obtener cinco soles en cinco volados
siempre va a ser igual a 1 ahora estas
probabilidades están muy interesantes
pero lo que realmente queríamos llegar
es la probabilidad sin estar
condicionando con ninguna otra cosa cuál
es la probabilidad de que salgan cinco
soles en cinco lanzamientos y pues eso
es igual a la probabilidad de sacar 5
soles en 5
volados los lanzamientos que son lo
mismo dado que tenemos a la moneda
normal por la probabilidad de sacar a la
moneda normal más la probabilidad
condiciones de sacar 5 soles en 5
volados
condicionado a que sacamos a la moneda
que tiene dos soles
por la probabilidad de sacar a la moneda
que tiene dos soles ok de hecho lo
podemos ver en este árbol o sea estamos
aquí y llegamos a este nodo en el cual
sacamos a la moneda normal y de este
nodo pues salen muchas ramas o sea la
rama en la que salen cinco soles en esos
cinco lados la rama en la que salen
cuatro soles en esos cinco lados la rama
en la que no sale ningún sol y todo ese
tipo de ramas no sin embargo nos fijamos
en esta rama en la que si salen cinco
soles y calculamos su probabilidad dado
que estábamos en este nuevo y esa
probabilidad es esta de aquí ahora si
queremos sacar la probabilidad total de
este nodo en general de cualquier nodo
en cualquier árbol de probabilidad lo
que tenemos que hacer es calcular la
probabilidad de llegar a este nuevo dado
que estamos en este nodo que es justo
esto de aquí que ya calculemos
es 1 entre 32 y multiplicarlo por la
probabilidad de llegar a este nuevo dado
que estamos en este nuevo que en este
caso es 9 décimos ok entonces la
probabilidad total de este nuevo que voy
a poner por aquí es 1 entre 32 por 9
décimos pero además fíjate eso es justo
lo que está escrito en esta fórmula o
sea tenemos aquí la probabilidad de n
que es justo 9 decimos que lo estamos
poniendo por acá por la probabilidad
condicional de 5 soles en 5 colados dado
que sacamos una moneda normal que es
justo esta probabilidad que sacamos aquí
y que estamos multiplicando por aquí
ok entonces todo esto de aquí es igual a
esto de aquí que sale naturalmente de
seguir este árbol ya que esta
probabilidad la debemos de haber escrito
tal vez en esta rama pero bueno se ve
más bonita por acá y bueno pasa lo mismo
para que no sea queremos llegar
a este nodo a este punto en el cual
tenemos 5 soles en 5 volados volados y
además sacamos a la moneda que tiene 2
soles
entonces para llegar a la probabilidad
de llegar a este nodo lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular la probabilidad de
llegar a este nodo sin importar cuántos
otros nodos haya aquí dado que estamos
en este nodo y esa probabilidad es esta
que ya vimos que es un 1 y multiplicarlo
por la probabilidad de llegar a este
novo dado que estamos en este otro nodo
pero como este no es el inicial entonces
esta probabilidad es 1 entre 10 por 1
entre 10 y podemos ver que lo que está
escrito aquí es justo lo que calculamos
que es la probabilidad de llegar a este
nuevo aunque es la probabilidad de sacar
la moneda con dos soles por la
probabilidad condiciones de sacar cinco
soles en cinco poblados dado que estamos
tirando a la moneda que tiene dos soles
que es justo esta probabilidad de aquí
que habíamos calculado que era 1 y
finalmente la probabilidad de que se
cumpla alguna condición como es sacar 5
soles en 5 volados es la suma de las
probabilidades de todos los nodos
que cumplen con esa condición
entonces si efectivamente tenemos que
sumar esta probabilidad más esta
probabilidad o sea tenemos que sumar
esta con esta entonces nos queda un 30 y
2 szabó por 9 decimos 9 entre
320 más uno por uno entre diez uno entre
diez que bueno podemos multiplicar
numerador y denominador por 32
32 y entonces esta suma es igual a 41
entre 320 entonces sin saber nada de
nada de cuál es la moneda que escogimos
la probabilidad de sacar 5 soles en 5
volados es 41 entre 320
ahora te voy a hacer una pregunta
muchísimo más interesante y de hecho es
de las cosas super útiles y es qué pasa
si tomas la moneda haces los cinco
lanzamientos y en los cinco lanzamientos
te salen cinco soles lo que la pregunta
que quiero hacer es cuál es la
probabilidad de que la moneda que hayas
tomado haya sido la que tiene dos soles
dado que acabas de observar que los
cinco lanzamientos salieron cinco soles
pero bueno para analizar esto
necesitamos más espacio
a ver entonces la pregunta que te estoy
haciendo es cuál es la probabilidad de
que hayamos tomado la moneda que tiene
dos soles dado que hicimos cinco volados
volados y en los cinco volados salieron
soles
5 soles ok ya lo viste muy bien si se
nota la diferencia entre esta
probabilidad y la probabilidad de sacar
5 soles
volados dado que tenemos a la moneda que
tiene dos soles cierto a ver de esta ya
la calculamos y si tenemos la moneda que
tiene dos soles y la lanzamos cinco
veces
obviamente nos van a salir cinco soles
entonces esta probabilidad es de uno sin
embargo esta probabilidad es otra cosa
completamente distinta o sea aquí
tenemos información acerca de los
volados y con ella queremos calcular
cuál es la probabilidad de que tengamos
cierto tipo de moneda ok entonces se
pone muy interesante lo voy a resolver
analíticamente en el próximo vídeo así
es que no te lo puedes perder